Evo the mecca of the fighting game
community a tournament series so
legendary just saying its name conjures
up images of glorious victory crushing
defeat and of course the highest levels
of hype download company live with Evo
2017 now behind us we thought it was
only fitting to look back at the
tournament illustrious 15-year history
and relive some of its most
unforgettable stories though these are
the most iconic moments in Evo history
between 2001 and 2010 Justin Wong was
the undisputed god of Marvel vs. Capcom
2 his dominance was unprecedented
cementing his status as a favorite in
the North American FCC Justin's
nine-year reign appeared to have no end
in sight but that all changed with the
release of Marvel vs. Capcom 3 part of
his decline was his stubbornness as
Justin stuck to a relatively weak team
and his dogged devotion to it eventually
cost him his crown he shoots many 50
champion at Evo 2011 he finished third
in 2012 seventh and in 2013 second even
Justin's most devout fans began to
question whether he would ever reclaim
his Marvel vs. Capcom Evo title as he
fell again and again two familiar rivals
Filipina can't dominate at but at Evo
2014 a chance for redemption presented
itself in the top eight justin had the
opportunity to reclaim the MVC throne
and exact revenge on the very usurpers
he had conceded it to his ter started
with evo2013 champion Jobe slaughter
free gorilla
really hard 36 2 o'clock but did not
find anything matter you got the itch 3
put your hands up now talk is the one
that have to make something happen
well that was flat oh I got it back
right there yeah so with a classic
Marvel Select oh nine seconds all of the
tempo change beautiful it's just the
world of hit for the winner on it next
was evil 2012 champion the controversial
Ryan Filipino champ who Ramirez is not a
good look look at what you have
Dominus like this first of all as you
have to cross the highest ability no
champ wouldn't roll over clock avoiding
2x but ain't going to be a lot of combat
round three was hotly contested Oh
Philip your combat last night amazing
combat Beijing the beat can't pull back
to fourth round against the time what's
on your workout form a full swing nice
hot dog the public angling and fireball
you're trying to set up it up it all
came down to round
[Music]
with two of his biggest demons cast
aside the stage was set for grand finals
their awaited Christopher Gonzales
better known as Chris G one of MVC
threes all-time greats and Justin's
toughest foes the one that everyone
asked for they wanted Justin Long and
Christian doesn't have to be the savior
of our first cab concrete Chris G had
had Justin's number throughout the year
so it was set to be a classic and it did
not disappoint
so we needed to come back how open are
like the things about Chris Stuart but
it didn't work out one barely off the
mark and you still had the x-factor
Ruffy really needed to make a comeback
Adam wrong number one one oh my god he
smells me crazy still look a girl right
now but it's refocus look at window
people under Wow bad bad all factor
either like that I was really cool
they're going to be close it's going to
be close couple more focus really my
doing he's killing a time right it was a
super - yeah oh my god you got it I
think Justin got it oh my god I pressed
the situation with dust Chris gene
fought tooth and nail to take the third
round
so common Eddie's actually a dangerous
enemy Otto's notice okay he got act
correctly but in the fourth Justin would
not be denied the war filler to our
oldest Anna trauma Justin wanted more
Justin wanted more oh my god he went to
like the game aspect oh my god will we
crown a new champion is a this might be
looking reserved as a mobile gun as
referred to his rope
I think what's on it be it I'm not even
gonna knock it yet I'm not even gonna
come buddy oh my god he sinks it he
found it on the lievable he's back
Justin had reclaimed his throne avenging
losses to his demons along the way and
the crowd could not have been happier
about it
[Applause]
that was the sickest thing I've ever
Catholic if anybody's going to remember
something it's a lot of moments
does it go to remember of Justin but
that's going to be my number one it's
like he lost Evo it was very depressing
they came back stronger the next year
one that way it's not every day that you
get to see someone redeem themselves on
the largest competitive stage and
especially to do it in such emphatically
the toughest of opposition Justin Wong's
impressive trail of destruction at Evo
2014 is every bit as unforgettable as
the barrel roll celebration it produced
undoubtedly making it one of Marvel's
most hype and iconic stories Pop's mouth
I can't believe it if there's one thing
you should know about Lee moon cochon
gone it's that he has a unique habits
whether it's in defiant frustration or
passionate celebration Foucault loses
his shirt
while pouco bare-chested tradition is
famous in the fgc there is one instant
that took it to iconic status and it
happened when he ran into Casey
oniisan Dillon during pool play of
ultimate Street Fighter 4 at evo 2015
realistically only son was no match for
Punk oh and the first match proved at
the marmar all and very impossibilities
and who coach is all over here o.o again
no cross up and you're in big trouble
not quite in range for the co taps but
while oniisan landed a few blows of his
own it was a confident 204 Punto
but that's when things got interesting
after the beatdown
oniisan eyed the crowd knowing he was on
stage with the rage master himself he
decided to make his match a bit more fun
he wanted the full punko experience in
all its angry shirtless glory and so
only sonim got to his feet and baited
the dance Oh
Oh card Oh
sorry pepperoni ziti hard whoa no y'all
go in it he's taking it well
buco simmered oh my oh and then erupted
if oniy son wanted to co-teach allah
please cut to the game through a barrage
it goes out of that base not one sit-up
okay here we go
every done the single sit-up yeah okay
nice uppercut put your shirt on my
shoulders I don't know it is I don't
know amigo God sir I'm near could you
remove your sloppy oh I was going to put
his shirt back on and then both ah and
another lopsided smack down by the
Korean in round two sealed the deal
you're in trouble now right down to the
wire here
oniisan
Oh donated right at that school did you
see the IRA proposal he did not even
want to take it hand then this game
wasn't a meeting between two juggernauts
and it's not some epic match you can
learn from every time you watch it but
it's funny memorable and it's pure fgc
spirit and that's what makes it iconic
Alex VA is a legend of the FCC he was
the de facto best player in the West
during the late 90s and his skill during
that era brought him neck and neck was
Daigo Umehara his influence on the west
coast scene simply cannot be understated
[Applause]
but by 2015 vias focus had shifted away
from competing towards other FCC
commitments leading many to believe that
his best years as a player were well
behind him that is until the
affectionately dubbed uncle VA entered
Ultra Street Fighter 4 at Evo 2015 where
he would defy all expectations further
building upon his already cemented
legacy in pools via found himself
matched up against the heavily favored
Masato banchan Takahashi banchan had
placed second at the previous Evo in
2014 and was considered a contender for
top eight in 2015 no matter how
experienced by a might have been there
was no way a past his prime old guy
could stand up against an elite next
generation street fighter player right
well we couldn't have been more wrong
not only did the old master be ponch and
he took him to school dad maybe
always going to be able to get a class
okay so this is the problem and buy it
with a fairly low humming get it got the
Waldo and the Ulta too and I would have
done it
oh my god the hell bow to the fate of
people alibi
counting it off of it not that time
though not going to call that situation
and I guess just can't be balling him
with this Hugo beautiful state the old
man's still got it idiot Alex by taking
the first game off of ponch and the
second round was more of the same kind
of guy it doesn't really matter what
you're moving it doesn't matter what
your notes aging game you better just
look down alright all you can do it I've
just been really hurting hold on it slap
him in the face
slap him in the face Melling blood in
the water VA went in for the kill takes
a meter at well having my date the new
land
put the halter crew is not going to be
enough quite yet but he's right there
what's the ball fight coming [ __ ] in
the loser's bracket no one would have
predicted the upset but it was the kind
of magic that could only have been made
a TiVo via one of the forefathers of the
fgc showing the naysaying
whippersnappers he could still hang with
the elites although he may not have gone
deep in the bracket after beating
banchan does it really matter for one
more beautiful moment we got to seeing
him kicking ass and taking names nearly
two decades after making his own is not
going to be enough quite yet
but he's right there what's the ball
valets lopsided upset of banchan reminds
us that the greatness of an FCC God
never truly fades even if his hair
colored their father so we can dare to
play from super smash bros melee at evil
2016 a highlight that has become a
defining moment for the entire smash
community and their journey at evo the
moment is significant as not just an
amazing and incredibly clutch play but
also for the emotional significance it
held for one hungrybox Viviana and his
fans
it seemed that H box was cursed to
always be the bridesmaid and never the
bride but during the grand finals of evo
2016 he finally got his chance to
exorcise his demons
back-to-back runner-up in 2014 and 2015
he came in to evil 2016 with a fresh
mindset his best friend and coach to
back him up and more Drive than ever to
take the mêlée throne sitting on that
throne was the Swedish god ego favorite
and undeniably best player in the world
Adam Armada Lindgren I feel pretty good
I had a pretty good 2015 overall and I'm
really really looking forward to this
weekend and I hope to defend my title
the two had met countless times before
with Armada usually getting the better
of hbox and his pub
[Applause]
go ahead take it evil for the first time
a Wyatt to add to the drama age box was
coming from losers and therefore had to
be Armada into to secure the title was
as close as it had ever been
Wow
do those
it came down to an all-important Game
five
if Armada won he would take the crown
and it would be another year of falling
just short for hbox you want to do you
want to see the reset if you want to go
down to the very end
big poster box here we go Game five
great night yes
bar keeping it on
with first off Chamonix
well we got a package of drag forever oh
wait there you go
I published there that the continent
like ugh
oh the Swede looked in control and he
was sent to slam the door on the Florida
natives hopes once again that's when
each box came in clutch
[Music]
you gotta play Oh
despite being down a stock and at nearly
100% each box managed to take out Armada
twice taking the final stock with the
rest heard around the world the shock on
H box's face and the roar of the crowd
tell you all you need to know about how
unlikely the comeback was looking with
that amazing clay h boxes work wasn't
done yet
he might ever set the bracket but he
still had to beat his rival once again
in another best of five if he didn't
close it out it would all be for nothing
but H box would not waste his
opportunities Oh
delivering on the dirt
red told the basketball there to serve
still be in the let's rock
dammit you didn't go to do it just go
with that
well okay spiced rhetoric assorted 139 I
don't think you could cloud sample much
bigger than that
come on a plate the vertical game wraps
cancels into a sign not an opportunity
agenda together open sky yet one
classifier let's go to the dial good
uses the biogenesis simply recover the
winner
overcome with emotion hbox had finally
achieved his dream winning an Evo title
and taking down Armada in the most
dramatic fashion possible while the
reset would probably be iconic in its
own right the fact that ace box actually
won it all is what makes the moment
embody his two-year struggle and
ultimate triumph on the grandest stage
melee has ever known the reset is
dramatic
unbelievably clutch and overwhelmingly
emotional making it not just one of
smash and Evo's most iconic moments but
one of the most inspiring stories in all
of eSports sometimes a little surprise
factor goes a long way
it's topping for Super Street Fighter 4
Arcade Edition at Evo 2014 and Lee
infiltration seon-woo is playing
Edoardo PR Balrog rez and loser semi
final winner takes top 3 loser goes home
the match was intense from the get-go
with PR Balrog throwing haymakers and
putting on the pressure to win the first
round oh yeah hold it up here specialty
Berto Rico's got a lot to be proud of
today but infiltration quickly adapted
taking confident back-to-back rounds to
win Game one oh and that's the pursuit
that's why you are not metering through
the fireball focused sample it
dashboards presented preventing it
seemed like the Korean might be able to
deal with PR Balrogs fiery aggression
control the pace and take the win but
Balrog wasn't going down without a fight
on these lievable four consecutive round
wins and infiltration reeling and with
all the momentum on his side
PR Balrog was grinning with confidence
one match away from securing his spot
and the losers final infiltration knew
he needed to do something anything to
stop PR Bell rug staring silently at the
screen and thought he dug deep into his
bag of tricks and pulled out Hakan wait
Hakan yes pecan while the oil wrestler
was considered a low tier no one knew
how to counter him pecan is a hard
counter to Balrog this is a very very
tough fight for Balrog not one you have
to face very often the crowd is on their
feet they're learning from it however
few players on earth could play him at
the high level needed to make this sort
of comeback fortunately for infiltration
he was one of those players before a
tournament you will be information and
education as it is which because did you
make it now except his air technology
even having to deal with the shock of
facing a hawk on PR Balrog wasn't making
it easily the final few rounds were
absolutely pulse counted Oh eat it right
in the snow and we are going to the
final round I think we are locked right
here put the head now to imagine nothing
came out final round again the whole key
is just left get away from that will
hook on one oil one of the strongest
characters in the game if not you
strongest character I want to wake up a
cutie using the es1 Hillerman big oil he
knew he was getting a pop word but it's
worth it for a con it opened up so many
options
and no big damage again using up that
oil time my mother's a real effort from
infiltration or even competitors pushing
equipment on great players out another
incredible air pro here's a buzzer a
game no he got away a battle rolls on
who focused up very Christian oh no
toilet okay founding generation he
dreading that fact wow so risky just
outraged Oh trying to beat it out role
play these upper parabolic gets away
with it living to fight another day but
looking a little bit training ghost
with a god out the wind wilted and
already famous infiltration into
legendary status and cemented his
reputation as a man who could not only
play any character but someone who would
do anything even gamble it all on Hakan
to win so this day no other character
swamp has come close to matching this
one when the low tier surprise became an
iconic moment in Street Fighter history
inflation with a cod knocking out your
bow incredible stuff amazing counterfeit
premature Popoff's are nothing new in
the world of the FCC but there is one
such moment that is so catastrophic in
its failure so memorable in its facepalm
inducing embarrassment that in just two
years it has already become the most
famous fgc blunder of all time it
happened during the guilty gear xrd top
eight at evo 2015 as Ruchi will she be a
shaggy know was taking on Kenichi Ogawa
Ogawa for a spot in the winner's final
these guys no stranger to each other
the match was tight from the get-go and
eventually had come down to a deciding
third game Oh gala went up one round
putting with she gaze back against the
wall I saw was she caked up up really
high knew the trajectory the pain was I
was one step ahead for the second round
came down to the wire but will she get
landed a well executed combo to narrowly
take it s caught roll again at the
person mediator though Oh Peter
caught up in the height of his perceived
victory will shake a pop to his feet and
face the crowd with both hands raised
it's too bad there was still around
oh my god
what's Theodore was over and student and
okay we'll give him no more
the FTC an internet exploded oh god
negative effect on unbelievable while
she gay would go on to aid in the design
of Street Fighter 5s mechanics this
infamous mistake immortalized him in the
annals of the fgc and evil when it comes
to iconic moments a failure can often be
just as memorable as success and as one
of the most costly and embarrassing
premature pop-ups of all time there's no
doubt that this one won't soon be
forgotten every now and then and
underdog emerges as the unlikely hero to
unexpectedly leave their mark on evo
history in 2010 it was the brilliance of
Bruce gamer be sang and in 2011 the fgc
stood in awe of Noah solace the
eight-year-old killer
I got it for the melee community at Evo
2014 it was Jeffrey axe Williamson who
propelled himself into smash legend by
not only playing one of the greatest
games of melee ever seen but doing so
with the most unlikely of characters
leading up to Evo acts had begun making
his name by placing respectably at
smaller events with Pikachu who back in
2014 was not viewed as a top tier
character his refusal to adopt a more
traditional main and still find success
had won him the affection of fans
thought their feet so an axe made it
into the top eight at Evo 2014 the crowd
was behind him a hundred and ten percent
standing in his way in the loser's
bracket was auto pilot wolf biz no a fox
player known for his technical prowess
all the bad Garrett's honest I was
taking it over at lesson today thought
it was going to be a tough matchup not
only with silent wolf a solid player Fox
is considered the strongest character in
melee leagues above Pikachu in the tier
list after splitting battlefield and
pokemon stadium their set came down to
the very last game on fountain of Dreams
acts a burst out of the gate rap and I
don't like the penalty counterfeit
formats because when a player has
technical at sound will be the change in
high school problems can really do a
loss I met to give up that's a thought
SP off-air self write and do today
nice life still not even trying to get
seals that has the children who get rid
of other stuff we got though within 45
seconds
silent wolf was down to stocks the crowd
roared and started chanting for pikachu
sensing that something special was about
to happen that trouble doubled really
quick the chant is rubbish here oh all
that pilot well we get a lot of force up
on the stage before 35 seconds so will
comes down to his last stop take a
mechanical for minute
happy whoa let's see we've ended yet oh
my god that was emphatic that was
amazing it took less than a minute for
ax to dismantle silent wolf in one of
the most brutal for socks in melee
history producing one of the most
electric Popoff's and hype sound bites
of all time oh my god hoisting is
Pikachu plushie up high axe bashed in
the rapturous cheers of the crowd an ego
defining image mortality are you
watching X's iconic for stock of silent
wolf stands as a lesson that matchups
aren't won on paper and that success can
still be found on path less traveled
not bad for a man in his electric mouse
when the gloves come off you know a
fight is about to get serious but in the
Mortal Kombat 10 grand finals at evo
2016 it wasn't gloves that came off it
was attacks
I don't think we've ever seen that
before but the fact that it belonged to
Dominique sonic box McLain makes this
story special because for sonic box his
hat is more than just a hat I like birds
a lot and then out of the ice so I could
still play was added paralyzed and make
a new image for myself by August of 2016
sonic Fox was the undisputed king of
mortal kombat
as you can see there the first place
Evo's who played for Team injustice and
mk9 play Lake champion this guy won the
very first ones in this game he had
taken down just about every big name in
the scene and dismantled Carl perfect
legend white to prove his status shop a
[ __ ] soul that was supposed to be his
around dude oh my god the bro yep you
guys the biggest object because Vegas
I'm hey he was on a rampage winning
title after title all while wearing his
fox tail and hat with ears even in the
most intense moments publicity shoots or
celebration sonic Fox was never ever
without his signature hat but during the
Grand Finals of evil 2016 something was
different his opponent Syed Tekken
master Hashim would push him further
than anyone else had before Oh
njp that exact No
wow that was a Christmas miracle oh man
that was so close he caught the njp for
the kill Tom Bobo man you cannot get
nervous on a stage like this the series
started with sonic Fox's Cassie cage
against Tekken masters Devorah and as
everyone expected game 1 was all sonic
Fox solidifying his lead sonic boxes
sitting ugly right now and I an eater
burn that's going to do it tekken master
switched to Kotal Kahn in game 2 and
that's when things started to get
interesting
hey beautiful work tekken master staying
on top of things
and now it may be time to take him out
to take advancement he has a lot of
advantage there oh man he's staggering
the part across really well for chip
well he can chip off this is dying
things up here and look at Sonic's Fox
that's the first game you've lost today
am i right you are right here with a
ryokan play I think even when Sonic Fox
switched onto the signature air in black
tekken master continued to make the MK
King sweat while the armor through the
command grab that was perfect timing
like economic had to bring oh we could
see the round folks we could idiot oh
man and the farmer slicing through Wow
look at this Facebook this look on dark
Fox's way I don't think I've ever seen a
make that me do not these areas nothing
at the end interesting maybe hip is
going to become a huge stock or now hold
on CBC on they go together you can take
it all he this is one more hand over to
me feeling like a what progress oh that
was the low mix up there look at sonic
boxes think this dunya is it took it no
oh man sorry boss
can he do it but gain he's looking for
the es it didn't come I'm covering my
eyes 9 Brackett Reed said protectant
after and you
with the bracketry set and sonic box
feeling the heat tech a master didn't
let up even for a second right about
that ego look or if the lead tech and
master
oh that was lasted it didn't want to do
it immediately there's the slide
second master trying to go up one oh and
it's Randy when do I defend to it you go
oh man frustrated and sensing oncoming
defeat sonic box did something no one
could have expected he took off his hat
whoa I don't think we've ever seen that
before
hi worth being Phil man bareheaded human
sonic watch his brain would be about
there It was as if the moment was
scripted like Bruce Lee taking off his
shirt in fists of fury the removal of
sonic fox's hat was a clear sign that
things were about to get real and they
did even though the drops it drops on a
crosswind you ever see it why beater
burn that they're using to the press and
the party crasher off of the back - look
gorgeous tech investor trying to get
something going look at all the meter
here though breaker have one left
what's he going to do
the big defense me Otto cannot run over
that Captiva or waffled red card do that
he's going to convert he's got lead he's
got the position choose his demeanor
burned all the Train on the fireball
atomic box take the lead and a set tech
and master wasn't done just yet
taking game 4 to tie the series and
putting himself one step away from
stealing the title out from under sonic
box emergency sound the alarms on it
Hawk again Oh
emergency but now he has far what would
we do with it we'll shoot and he goes
for dad and water damage their blog and
it is all tied up to to evolution 2016
look at these players right now
this is unbelievable nobody's wearing a
blue hat I can't be one last character
switch was an order finally brings out
the secret with no more dilly dallying
here oh I'm all right
there's alien pressure in the corner got
it at the Ike saw our breaker here
overhead
coming I Love Lucy what are we gonna do
the blog it's fine now okay and us know
the man that was a mistake
area was we're right back into the
corner look at this so we are Co no
problems out a second map it's a
heartbreak he's been punishing me miss
humbles you have to make a big recovery
immediately he's got a damaged ball
throw brick he finds the head friends
that will be a lot this is the secret
box here the alien all man second master
with barely any help
the celebration sonic box just like that
sonic boxer Rupp did to his feet he was
the champion as for the hat it lay on
the table where he had left it a symbol
that sonic box had been pushed to his
limit and emerged victorious since then
sonic box has remained a nearly
unstoppable force in the world of mortal
combat and no one will forget the only
time he took off his hat ooh and sorry
oh I don't think we've ever seen that
before this is the play that needs a
little introduction it is not only the
most iconic fgc moment of all time it
stands among the greatest esports
players of all time in
from Street Fighter third strike at Evo
2004 Evo moment 37 emerged from a
matchup that is a classic to this day
justin wong vs Daigo Umehara it was the
american whiz kid against the japanese
beast and while the match was destined
to be a thriller no one could have known
that what would happen would change
fighting games forever with both players
earning themselves around a piece the
first game came down to a deciding round
3 Justin took a commanding lead
with Daigo one strike away from defeat
justin throughout chun-li's hoyou coos
and super a 15 strike attack he figured
Daigo would drop an input gambling that
the Beast wouldn't be perfect for just
one split second
he was wrong
[Applause]
the Daigo Perry is unbelievable because
any of the hips even if block would have
been enough to knock daegil out and give
Justin the first game
Daigo had to perfectly time his Perry's
for all 15 strikes which requires nearly
frame perfect input on top of doing just
that
he ended the fight with his own super
stealing one of the flashiest and most
unbelievable comebacks of all time
[Applause]
it's easy to see why evil moment 37 has
become such an iconic moment in eSports
history it's the perfect storm of
everything you need to make an amazing
highlight fierce competitors a tight
crowd in a play that defied all
expectations
it is simply put what the FTC and evil
are all about wrapped up in one
beautiful untouchable high light
[Applause]
it is evil moment 37 we love producing
these videos and hope you enjoy them
just as much is there a story you think
that you should tell leave your
suggestions in the comments below and be
sure to subscribe for more great content